boombox the vegas residency on shuffle
is set to launch wednesday at the west
gate featuring hosts kid and play and
performances from celo green tone lok jj
fadd snap and legendary dj eric b who is
joining us now welcome to the show man
yeah it's great to see you great to be
here and you are a las vegas resident
been here for five years how do you like
live in las vegas lake las vegas is the
place that's the place to be this is the
place i don't i don't like my doors i
don't do i just come in here come in and
out everybody minds their business great
greatest living i've ever had you like
the heat compared to the easter i love
the heat i love it it's because it's dry
heat it's not like a new york train
station oh my gosh
the humidity back east exactly it's
unbearable at times that's what i'm
saying this is a dry heat so i welcome
you so what can we expect of the show
this is huge we're so excited for me
it's i'm getting i'm working with my
family yeah kid and play we all grew up
together in the same neighborhood
ceelo green we always check on each
other every month hey how you feeling jj
fed they've been around us for the last
30 years i mean it's going to be like a
family reunion so you guys all get along
guys hang out of course i always we all
call each other kid and play hey eric
how you feeling what you doing today so
it's not like you know they're here and
i'm here we're all family we all check
on each other every month i love hearing
that because some of these shows that
people get a long backstage you guys get
along with they'll feel the energy of
those kids we grew up in the same
neighborhood you guys are hanging out
yes yeah we hung out as kids went to
school and everything your journey you
started as a dj back east yes with you
your grand vision is this how you saw
everything play out no i wish it was
yeah i tell everybody they asked me eric
did you see this i said no not at all
never seen it coming i just did
something just to get out of the streets
that made me feel good you know kept me
out of trouble and just we just kept
making music me and rock kim just kept
making music and it kept us out of the
streets of new york okay so you're also
doing some acting too with blue blood
i'm on cbs yeah right cbs friday night i
think it's 10 o'clock here friday nights
i know in new york it's 10 o'clock
friday nights i play lieutenant mike g
how do you like playing lieutenant well
it's a gift from the curse because when
i play lieutenant mike g so i have a
pantry in new york city of first baptist
church in new york city we have a pantry
okay so we feed a couple of thousand
people every week
so the old ladies that work in there
help they love me but they hate me
they're like they're blue blood's
friends city like eric so if you see me
on blue bloods either donny got a
partner has a problem so one day i was
gonna i took her gun from her and i said
man how am i gonna go to the church
today these old ladies are gonna kill me
they called me they say eric we love you
we love you but we hate you what are you
gonna do this time eric are you going to
take donny's shield too i'm like oh you
can't win you can't win
you had to choose when acting or
performing on stage with a crowd
what do you prefer acting yeah acting i
mean you know the the cast that we have
at blue bloods the people behind the
scenes they push each other their family
and we have a great time great directors
we have a great time there let's do a
little word association before we wrap
things up because this this is going to
be this residence at the west game the
west gate is going to be bombers okay
silo green i'm going to be the artist
and song the first thing that pops in
your mind ceelo green crazy
ceelo is crazy
he is he is the he is the essential
crazy but a great guy yeah one of the
greatest guys you ever want to meet tony
wilding it's on locust wild i've been
around tung lok 100 times we used to
watch football together and stuff he's a
wild guy okay that works for him kidding
play ain't going to hurt nobody
that's not true because when we were
kids they were kind of dangerous guys
no no they wasn't bullying me but they
weren't they weren't what you expected
what you see now snap rhythm is a dancer
that's gonna be that's a great right
that's a great song that's a record
that'll keep going on for another two
three hundred years
circle back real quick you live in las
vegas are you a golden knights fan yes i
mean you know i'm actually a cowboys fan
oh my gosh i'm a cowboys fan too a
cowboys fan but the cowboys are like old
girlfriends they let you down every year
every single season this is gonna be our
yeah
can't wait for you to come to the show
i'll be there man to get your tickets to
boombox the vegas residency on shuffle
visit
westgateresorts.com the residency starts
wednesday and runs through uh september
4th and the 28th then they got shows in
october it's happening all the time
jillian over to you thank you